Avishai, we're meeting here in Jerusalem. Given the topic of our conference 'What Will Save the World?'..
Jerusalem is a quite curious place.
In Jerusalem there is this claim that they
know what will save the world
the messiah, the new messiah, the return
of the messiah, Judaism, Christianity, Islam.
What's your take on that?
There is something which is called
'the Jerusalem syndrome'.
The Jerusalem syndrome is that there is
a certain kind of madness
which is associated with Jerusalem.
Really mad people coming with visionary ideas about..
.. a sort of global, eschatological ideas.
They've really gone raving mad in towns.
It's a name by now, I think..
..of a genuine..
..disease.
So you basically ask me to talk like someone with
the Jerusalem syndrome.
First of all, I don't think the world is in danger. I don't think that the world...
I think that basically the world is safer now than..
..than it was fifty years ago.
Then there was the polarity of..
..when people were terrified of nuclear war.
The talk about terrorism is overblown.
Not that there is no terrorism.
Unless you call terrorism every organization
that you dislike.
But if by 'terrorism' you mean sort of..
..yeah there will be more terror.
.. but it's not a danger to the world..
I don't believe that..
..terrorism can stop..
..let's say what the pirates did in the Mediterranean
..they stopped the Mediterranean traffic
for 400 years, 500 years.
I don't think that anything of that sort..
..is about to happen.
I'm neither a cultural pessimist, and not an optimist.
I don't see..
It will be a different world.
That people like me will find congenial,
and may be not.
But at least strange.
I'm not adaptable..
..or ready for the gadgets that are now.
The main thing is whether..
.. the Gutenberg revolution:
the printing culture..
..is about to disappear and be replaced
by something else.
In some sense it's already happening, on the other hand people are reading more books now than ever.
Then ofcourse there's the issue of
the climate change.
Which I believe is real. So if 'saving the world'
is saving the planet..
..in the sense of doing something
about the climate change..
..that's a serious problem.
I don't believe it can be done on a retail basis,
that each individual will try to behave.
..it's really for the big powers to negotiate.
Namely the United States, China mainly..
.. India, all the places that are developing. That's serious.
But that's about it..
..what I see as real danger.
Our civilization, or these civilizations will be transmuted or will be transformed.
Some of us will like the direction in which it is going, some of us not.
I hear more and more pessimism around me. I know I'm surrounded by people like me, that are simply aging.
And it's a syndrome about us, not about the world.